en una muy breve declaración pero siendo
la primera oficial en la que se
interpela explícitamente a rusia el
ministro de exteriores de israel ya isla
pib condenó el ataque de rusia a ucrania
calificándolo de grave violación al
orden mundial al orden internacional se
trata de una de las declaraciones más
duras de israel hacia rusia desde la
guerra de georgia en 2008 pero por ahora
no se espera que vaya a ir más allá no
se espera que israel vaya a estar más
contundente contra el presidente ruso
vladimir putin y esto se debe a una
razón estratégica y es que podríamos
decir que a israel no le conviene
enfadar lo o decepcionar lo ya que rusia
además de tener presencia militar
controla parcialmente el espacio aéreo
de siria permitiendo como hemos visto
esa semana que israel incursiones o
ataques y objetivos iraníes en este país
con quien comparte fronteras en el norte
pero además esta relación estratégica
conveniente podemos decir que desde los
años 2000 rusia e israel han mantenido
unas buenas relaciones diplomáticas
siendo obviamente israel el único país
parcialmente ruso fono fuera de los
antiguos estados soviéticos
con toda esta relación el ministro de
exteriores- lápiz nos ha olvidado del
pueblo de ucrania pero sobre todo ha
tendido la mano ha recordado a las
comunidades judías e israelíes en este
país a las primeras que se cifran en
unos 200.000 judíos en ucrania les ha
atendido acogida mientras que a las
segundas que son entre 6.000 y 8.000
israelíes en ucrania les ha pedido que
por favor acudan lo antes posible por
vía terrestre a las fronteras del oeste
en este sentido a través del ministerio
de exterior israelí ha desplegado
personal oficial para poder ayudar a la
evacuación de todas estas personas que
lo quieran entre los cruces de ucrania y
los cinco países limítrofes al oeste